the Linea aquavit distillery near Oslo
produces some two and a half million
bottles a year of the clear schnapps it
gets its distinctive flavor from a
coincidence that dates back more than
200 years in 1805 when both a brig
called Troma's River went from Trondheim
actually the all the way down to Batavia
and back again the ship was loaded with
barrels of aqua be aimed at opening new
markets for the distillery but it didn't
work out and two years later the ship
returned with its cargo of unsold
schnapps but it turned out the long
voyage had mysteriously improved the
flavour and that as this commercial
shows was the beginning of the Dini
aquavit
uh slows market hauls are popular with
gourmets this is a great place to buy or
eat fresh fish and seafood most people
eat their fish with a beer and then
maybe an aqua beat afterwards Norway's
national beverage it's consumed at room
temperature not ice-cold Norwegians also
cook with aquavit there are plenty of
recipes or use it to marinate food like
salmon nine thousand oak barrels are
stacked here each contains 500 liters of
aquavit it'll be stored here for 12
months
these perils count from Paris in Spain
they have been previous used for Larusso
chattering and we going down to Harris
pick out our barrels taking the home and
we're just filling the equate into the
into the barrels a backhoe it is
actually taking the rest of survey into
the into the product in addition to the
sharing other flavors are added to
enhance the basic potato distillate
we are now in the heart of a Coquette
production this is the distilling room
here with the distill the herbs and the
spices which we use in the Linea poly we
use
caraway and we also be used star anise
as some of the spices we usually talk
about the caraway and the star anise and
the rest of the spices we like to keep
as a secret
what's not a secret is that after 12
months storage in Oslo the barrels are
packed into shipping containers and sent
on a long voyage as in 1805 the barrels
are loaded onto the deck of a ship along
with many other goods the ship then
travels to Australia and after four
months returns to Norway after having
crossed the equator twice
when the aquavit is traveling the liquid
inside the barrels is moving and you
have a different matter ation than if
the barrel shouldn't be lying here in
the warehouse after its journey the
aquavit is bottled each bottles label
includes the name of the ship in this
case a ship named Texas and the dates of
the voyage
if you see through the bottle into the
etiquette you will find the date when
the barrels left Oslo and you will see
the date when the barrels will echo it
arrived to Oslo the ship is carrying the
Kaka weight into several harbours all
around the world actually it's the trip
across the equator the line that gives
the aquavit its name the motion of the
sea and the changing weather are the
factors that make Lena Akwa beat
something special something reflected in
the company's slogan some journeys
change you forever
you